there's more to this drone than meets
the eye
the team behind this bot took
inspiration from nature to design a
device capable of morphing to suit its
environment
transforming to most efficiently tackle
the challenge in front of it
[Music]
animals use their bodies in various ways
to suit different Terrain
meerkats may not be great at walking on
two legs but they can stand up when they
need to to scout out their surroundings
Turtle flippers may be optimized for
swimming but they can also haul the
reptiles up a beach when needed
and it was this ability to use
appendages for multiple functions that
inspired the design of this robot named
the multimodal mobility morphobot or M4
for short
M4 isn't the first robot to move in
multiple ways but the researchers behind
it say that previous designs mostly fell
into one of two camps those with Morpho
functionality like this robot that can
reshape its limbs to walk or swim or
those that use redundancy having a set
of wheels and propeller blades to travel
on land or the sea
but M4 is different it can perform a
variety of tasks by using its same limbs
in different ways just like an animal
changing its posture or gait thus
finding a sweet spot between redundancy
and the ability to change shape and
function
in practice what this means is that M4
Can Fly And Roll as you might expect but
also tumble over obstacles
[Music]
balance on one end
Crouch under barriers
and crawl over Rocky Terrain
it can even manipulate this ball using
two of its propellers like hands
[Music]
when presented with a 45 degree ramp too
steep for Wheels alone the took
inspiration from the chukka Partridge
which uses its wings to help it run up
inclines they instructed M4 to do
something similar
M4 could of course just fly up the ramp
but rotors use much more energy than
wheels and so by combining the two modes
M4 can achieve the same goal much more
efficiently
the researchers argued that this
morphobot could be used for everything
from search and rescue to Future space
missions and want to expand on their
design to give M4 more sophisticated
tools and greater articulation they are
also working on algorithms that could
allow M4 to interpret data from sensors
and autonomously choose its mode of
Transport based on its surroundings be
that rolling flying or something in
between
thank you